Dameon last time we spoke was what maybe
three four months ago something yeah and
your story was incredible thank you you
know you you told the story I see a lot
of comments saying you know it's it's a
[ __ ] story yeah
six month old baby crawling out of a
lake to go back to the house that came
from is a little bit far-fetched but you
say it's still true yeah I mean they
told me separately mother and father
like they're talking about the weather
you know and they each told me on
different occasions and they hadn't been
together for you know many years you
know last time they were together I was
uh I was probably like maybe two years
old if that and so they haven't been
together for for that long no and you're
at least at the very most you were two
years old you know sometimes stories get
sometimes stories get exaggerated or
embellished I don't think I've told the
story about my youth it wasn't
exaggerated in some form right human
nature but from what they told me yeah I
was six months old had colic coughing
and I was a buzzkill and so they were
trying to fix and we're just having so
many problems with me coughing and then
having to pay attention to me
that they decided that we're doing this
no more we're driving down the road and
we're tossing this little hell a
helter-skelter hell you in whatever you
are those things in your first video
your dad was a biker yeah Hells Angel
right Hells Angels yes and your mom was
she was a biker [ __ ] I mean so your mom
actually another story you told was that
your mom murdered a guy in a hardware
store yeah and that's true that's that's
true as well i watch that i wat
physically watch that with my own eyes
how old were you I was like five or six
years old he cut us off and ran a red
light my mom ran a red light chasing him
because when he cut us off she slammed
on the brakes and we were in an old Ford
pickup truck no seat belts and I busted
my nose against the day
bleeding and stuff you know so that
pissed her off and then so she goes and
runs like a couple red lights you know
chasing this dude down he pulls into a
hardware store and she pulls in after
him and she's like wait in the [ __ ]
truck you know and I'm like all Yeah
right you know I want to see what's
going on you know I was a little kid you
know Curious George and so I got in or
got out and went in after her and just
saw her just mangled this guy like
literally until his body like stopped
moving and he stopped crying so yeah a
rough childhood sounds like yeah with
your parents what's going on today now
it's been several months yeah I mean
you're using fentanyl yeah still and
yeah and I went to detox so recently and
I like really proud of myself you know
but then I was kicking suboxone was in
the rehab place Rena be a beautiful
place you know awesome place and for
some reason though my psyche like
flipped out on me like I went wingnut on
myself and and just up and left the
place you know knowing damn good and
well that I had a better future ahead of
me in this place but for some reason my
psyche was telling me you're
incarcerated you're locked up you need
to get out of here we we can't do this
locked up thing you know and so for some
reason instead of walking out of the
front gate which I could have done I
died I packed up my stuff and I jumped
the [ __ ] wall but the second that I
got on the other side of the wall I like
started crying and kicking myself in the
ass like wondering what what was I doing
you know like I I really didn't
understand you know what do you think
that's all about
oh no I mean I want to say
psychologically speaking it's uh just
the primal side of me you know not
wanting to be incarcerated even though I
wasn't incarcerated I was in a place
that was nurturing me and taking care of
me and helping me the place was great
yeah but for some reason because I
couldn't walk outside of the facility
because I like to walk a lot you know
just see things you know and because I
couldn't do that I think that was like
the the main issue with me I'm not
really sure though do you think it could
have been just your almost some
subconscious belief of what you deserve
in life could be getting clean and
getting your life together or the fear
of that was was too much to deal with
that could very well be it I never even
thought about that one it yourself'
sabotage yeah because I've talked to so
many people now I've heard whether I
bring it up or not I hear these stories
and say it seems to me like they're self
sabotaging themselves their own their
own forward progress gets derailed yeah
hope something and I get thrown back
into the [ __ ] yeah you know I gotta want
to be there
you know I believe I am with I mean with
the good that I do for other people and
stuff and the good that I'd like to do
constantly I believe I deserve a better
life yeah usually you seem intelligent
more intelligent than most thank you my
longshot and self-aware enough to say
all right I'm making mistakes and I need
to not make mistakes but you still here
you are still yeah well this this is a
this is a really big helping hand for me
though right now because now I'm gonna I
mean what I'm gonna do with this is a
first and foremost buy me some new
clothes cuz I've been wearing these
clothes for like four months
okay and then I'm going to seed or
cyanide for their detox oh you are yeah
that's great and so how do you how do
you get into that program is it does it
cost you anything
med account pays for it and even do
rehab how many times once just at one
time yeah so this will be a second time
yeah good for you I mean I've always
wanted to but just in the past I always
beat myself up from my past you know
like with the I talked to you about
Thomas West right yes yeah about that
particular stuff you know that part
nobody doubts because I think there's
news newspaper articles yeah showing
that yeah and it's like for some reason
I was always beating myself up seeming
to think that that I was at fault you
know it to me as an outsider listening
to your story it seems to me like you
need to look at what those events and
that childhood with your parents kind of
what it would have communicated to you
about what you deserve in life because
because you believe not you believe you
deserve to live on the street like a
like a rat and that needs to change
because you can get clean from drugs and
that's a great thing but you'll end up
falling back into something just as
destructive if you still believe that's
what you deserve like you you're a great
guy you seem to deserve better and like
you were saying though I believe that
but my subconscious for some reason
doesn't yeah because I mean I get I get
so self-destructive and I'm not really
understanding that too much you know
hopefully when I go to Cedar sinai and
everything you know I'll try and get on
like do something new like it with a
psychologist or psychiatrist whatever
and you know hopefully try and remedy
the mental woes that are holding me down
you know no I mean being with
professional would be great move
thank you and I really enjoy the talks
how how do you you know you you offer
positive reassurance you know and you
help us out a lot I'd like if you have
the YouTube comments he helps us out a
lot so I mean you know you people should
like really lighten up on that
commenting thing you know well that's I
don't really show it like what I do
after your effort cameras off I never
show that stuff so everybody thinks I'm
just an exploitive bastard oh yeah most
certainly not
whatever I just let them think that they
want and make other people want to hate
yeah just just like I could say about
you and a lot of people have interviewed
that you just want to hate yourself and
that's not gonna change my me saying
don't hate yourself it's not gonna
change them the commenters for me saying
you know if they wanna hate what I'm
doing they're gonna hate what I'm doing
and if they get enough evidence so that
it's proven I can at least zip it you
know no I so many commenters are
supportive of what I'm doing that I just
hang on to those comments because there
is a lot of compassion that intelligent
aware people out there that are that are
hip to what I'm doing and a lot of
people just love to hate that's social
media as a
mother she loved hey no I mean like the
comments on your video the first one are
equally split between they think you the
greatest guy ever they want to help you
they like why is this guy not a brain
surgeon or doing something really great
with your the pool thing or something
like that because the lack of
opportunities well I mean there's also
the self-worth thing well yeah leave
dinner so just as you're intelligent
doesn't mean you're not you know there's
other obstacles other than intelligence
I could use some help though and I mean
you're offering it to me so I mean yeah
I think the rehab is a great great first
step but but talking to a therapist and
working on your what you believe about
yourself that's not your fault it's just
like things happen to you as a kid but
we try and process it you know and and
when the processing gets totally
confused in the semantics of it all you
can never really surmise like a proper
understanding you know especially with
yourself cuz I mean I I didn't know what
I was doing and what was wrong and what
was right at the time because I mean I I
grew up watching people get beat to
death and all kinds of horrible stuff
you know you know that that's got to
affect you as an adult
yeah there's no way it can yeah
excellent Damian thank you so much for
coming back and talking to me and good
luck with the rehab that sounds great
you very much I appreciate all that you
do for us I'm proud of you me thank you
thank you
awesome I appreciate you hopefully this
stain see you to sign and you know it'll
get some good positive in my life but
we're work on what you believe about
yourself too this is not your fault you
didn't pick your parents you didn't pick
that guy less to do that [ __ ] to you it
was out of your control at that age
now you have to keep reminding yourself
of that because it's very easy for you
to just decide that you're worthless
because of those kind of things that
happen to you and if you believe you're
worthless this is the neighborhood for
you no I think probably because it's the
easiest road to take it's an easy one
you don't try ya know cuz even even for
people like me that don't have these
drug addiction agent issues whenever you
still struggle to love yourself we still
do everybody does likewise because you
you are doing a lot of good for the
people out here